hello YouTube chest lowers no offense
this is guns in here and welcome to the
third part of dirty chest tricks now as
per the request from some of my
beginners to intermediate level
subscribers I am presenting this tricks
which can leads to very fast victory now
before we start there are a few points I
like to mention you only try this tricks
against the people who are below 1618
the simple reason is the occurrence of
this trick is very high on that level
and the second point is I strongly
insist that you only try this tricks in
the quick games so for example bullet of
the Blitz the good reason is in the long
game your opponent has ample time to
defuse it also the positive aspect is
you can play against the high rated
player at the right time to catch the
big fish on the hook so now keeping all
these things in the mind let's get
started when white plays the movie for
the most forcing opening from the black
perspective is the move
defy and this is known as Scandinavian
defense now here there are many moves
has been tried but imagine my surprise
which you are going to give your
opponent Knight to f3 and what can be
more natural than D captures e and here
we are going to play the
Knight to g5 so attacking the pawn and
more or less trying to regain the ball
especially and this is what happened in
the under 1600 people try to hang on
this point they think that okay
I've been upon so let me hang on and
that way I will be material up so here
black has a four replies and against
each of them I have some nice tricks for
you so the first obvious trick which I
am going to show you in the knight to f6
variation here I recommend that you play
d3 and now once again if black allows
white to regain the pawn then white
position is again fine so more or less
if black wants to be upon up then he has
to capture this pawn so across d3 and
now white is going to play Bishop cross
d3 we reach the critical position where
black has to decide what is going to do
now if you look at the position
carefully why it has a wonderful night
seated on g5 and what can be more
natural if your opponent is going to
keep this night well if your opponent is
not feeling well about that 9 then he
will be shocked after your next move
which is my cross f7
so you can see the night is [ __ ]
Queen and rook
so black response is pretty much forced
so black has to capture this night and
now White has the another tremendous
move Bishop to g3 Jack this Bishop is
not only checking the skin but it's also
preventing this king to go back to the
eh square which is the only square to
defend this Queen and if that square has
been blocked
that means white will simply be no Queen
the very obvious response is king cross
g3 afterwards white will simply snap up
the Queen so there is a first trick
exist in Knight to f6 line in second
line one of my opponent tried to hang on
to this one why a bishop to f5 okay no
problem
here white will once again attack the
pawn with another night and again black
has to somehow defend this point and
what can be more natural than Knight to
f6 and now you play a slightly
surprising move which is Queen to e2 so
attacking the pawn on the third time now
Queen to e2 is not the best move but
what it will do is it will force black
more or less to play this move which is
Queen to d4 so defending the pawn third
time with the Queen when your opponent
play this move you have more or less
chance to finish him off within five
moves so let's see those wonderful moves
so first obvious response is Queen to b5
check and this is quite nasty check
because you can already see not only its
attacking the bishop but it's also
attacking the b7 pawn so black response
is pretty much forced black has to save
a piece so black has to play Bishop to
d7 and now Queen is going to capture
this b7 pawn
and here I give you guarantee and this
happens many times most of the time your
opponent is going to play Bishop to c6
and they think oh not only I sail the
rook
but I also attacking the Queen well here
you are going to surprise your opponent
one more time with this wonderful move
Bishop to b5 so locking this Bishop and
now white is all set to capture this
rook
so again black has to play this forcing
move Queen to d7 so maybe black will
think okay if he's going to take my rope
then I'm going to take a screen and most
probably I will be exchanged down and a
playable position but now comes a big
shop which is Bishop cross c3 the most
obvious response is Queen cross c3 which
looks like saving everything but if you
carefully look at it boom that's a
checkmate this is a one kind of reverse
England gambit trap which occurs from
the white perspective so that is one
good trick exist in Bishop 2f final now
the thermal which I like to consider
which is a more Scandinavian type move
in to defy not only protecting the pawn
but it's also hitting this Knight
so white response is pretty much forced
so white has to play the move d3 so
protecting the night and once again
renewing the threat to capturing the e4
now if you open place Knight to f6 or
Bishop to a5 then white has a very
simple equivalent for example if you
open in place Knight to f6 then the very
simple will be Knight to c3 and after
Queen let's say goes to the FI then
white can capture this ball and not only
white is regaining the material but
white is also a heading development so
there will be no problem at all in this
variation so that's why if black wants
to retain any advantage then black has
to capture this pawn once again so black
has to play across d3 and here once
again we are going to capture with the
bush up which looks very odd because
right now you are giving up the g2 pawn
and not only that it also allow the
Queen to attack the rook so what can be
more natural and this especially happen
when you open is very greedy he is going
to capture the g2 pawn so Quinn cross g2
and once again black is falling for a
wonderful trick which is Bishop to e4
so not only it's attacking the Queen but
the Queen has the only square laughs
which is Queen to g4 afterwards White
has a simple reply queen capture screen
and after Bishop captures Queen can you
spot it yup a special cross b7 and black
will no sir okay so that is the one good
trick existing Queen d4 line now after
across d3 and Bishop cross d3 in one of
my game my opponent decided to go for
the another bond which is after Queen to
e5 check and when I block the check with
the Bishop to e3 he tried to grab the
another pawn so Queen captures b2 and
here I very simply play Knight to d2
although white is a couple of pawn down
but White has a tremendous piece
development and you will see what a
great dividend I am getting from this
tremendous development so here my
opponent continued with Knight to c6 I
castle on the Kings side and now he
played a nature looking move which is
like to have six but such an
asian-looking move in this kind of
scenario can be proved very disaster and
that you are about to see
so here I played night to see Phi
attacking the Queen and the funny part
is Queen has the only two square left
which is either before or the c3 now if
the Queen goes to the c3 then the rope
to be one is very very strong planning
his rook to b3 and nabbing the Queen so
in the game my opponent decided to play
Queen to b4 afterwards I played a very
forcing move which is the move c3 once
again attacking the Queen and once again
the funny part is Queen doesn't have
this time any squares left so Queen has
to forcefully capture this phone and now
white will play rook to c3 gaining more
time on the Queen and once again Queen
has the only square which is Queen to b4
afterwards the move
a3 believe it or not but NAB the Queen
if you look at your queen has the only
square left now which is Queen to be Phi
and that has been played in the game but
afterwards can you spot it yep it's
Knight to d3 check double attack to the
Queen and Queen is out of the game so
those are some of the nice trick exist
in Queen to defy line let's look at the
final option which is the MU f5
especially if you are playing a person
which is under 1500 you are likely to
get this move which is their file and
here I recommend that you play a simple
move Bishop to c4 so training on the
weakest spot
yep 7 and here black response is pretty
much forced black has to play nice to at
6 afterwards
white is going to play the move t3
again if black wants to retain any sort
of advantage then black has to capture
the spawn and here the surprising move
is see cross d3 so what's the idea of C
cross d3 so idea is very simple white
wants to play Queen to b3 after the
normal-looking move from the black which
is the move ePHI the Queen b3 is
straightaway on the car so you can
already see now the three pieces are
training on the f7 square so again black
response is pretty much forced black has
to play Queen to e7 and now white is
going to play Knight to c3 Knight wants
to come to the d5 square so black has to
stop it so black has to place a six and
now what is going to cancel and look at
the [ __ ] piece development of the
black all the pieces are sitting on the
back rack and not only that there are
nasty tricks exist here so for example
in one of my game my opponent try the
move b5 when you are behind in
development try to getting active is a
very wrong idea so here I simply capture
this pawn and after Seri captures white
played the straight forward move Bishop
to D file so attacking the rook and how
the black is going to defend this if we
try to play Bishop to b7 which looks
like it's defending the rook but after
Queen to B Phi jack blackness certainly
lose a piece so that's why B Phi is
impossible
instead of beef I the most nation
looking movies Knight to d7 since black
cannot castle on the kingside it's very
wise for black to quickly go for the
queenside castle and in most of the
scenario you will find this is the plant
your opener is going to try so against
this we are going to play again the
nature looking move which is rook to e1
and here black has the few choices if
black plays either Knight to f6 or night
to b6 for example let's say Knight to f6
then the very simple will be Bishop to
f4 and once again not only white will
regain this pawn and a tremendous attack
on the black King but look at the black
retired piece development so the most
critical move at this point is night to
c5 and after night to c5 White has to
retrieve the Queen because the knight
was attacking the Queen so the Queen has
to drop back at the c2 and again the
planning of the white is very simple
white owns to play either f4 or Bishop
to f4 and get the pawn back and get the
attack ruling so the obvious looking
response from the black is to go quickly
on the queenside castle now before we
look at that there is a again one funny
move played in one of my games so one of
my opponent try at this point to move B
Phi but this can be simply made with the
move
efore so please remember this ruk is now
eyeing at the ephah square and beyond
that it will pinned up clean
that means black response is pretty much
forced Black has to play the movie four
but now after very simple D cross if R
and B cross C for white can immediately
capture this e4 and because the Queen
and the king in a line black is in deep
deep trouble other response left is to
go quickly on the queenside castle and
Bishop d7 is the first step towards it
but here white can again diffuse this
whole idea by playing the MU D file so
again the same idea rook captures ePHI
so black response is pretty much force
black has to move the knight to e4 and
here white is going to capture this
Knight and after every captures and
light recaptures yes white allow black
to go on the queenside castling but not
without any compensation because white
will play the move Bishop to g5 and
securing Queen and the rope so at least
white will gain an exchange so those are
some of the nice tricks exist in Knight
to f3 variation of the Scandinavian I
hope you learn and enjoy this wonderful
tricks please try in your own game and
you will be amazed by its potential best
of luck and feel free to comment on my
video
I'll meet you soon bye